the number of undocumented children held
in Federal Detention Center's is growing
the Department of Health and Human
Services says nearly 12,000 minors are
living in its network of shelters right
now the majority tried to cross the
border on their own but an increasing
number were forcibly separated from
their families more than 800 kids were
brought to detention centers in just the
last week Adriana Diaz is outside a
shelter in Homestead Florida south of
Miami
Adriana good morning good morning the
government says that there more than one
thousand teenagers being held at the
facility behind me yesterday lawmakers
flew down from DC to try to see the
conditions for themselves it is our
responsibility to make sure that those
children are cared for and to see that
they are reunited with their parents
Florida Senator Bill Nelson and
congresswoman debbie Wasserman Schultz
came to the homestead temporary shelter
for unaccompanied children Tuesday with
a mission but they were stopped by
security children this is an an absolute
outrage aerial shot on Monday shows some
of the teens currently living at the
facility which is overseen by the US
Department of Health and Human Services
this 2016 video is the only view inside
that the government has provided a
former agency employee familiar with the
shelter told CBS News it was originally
designed under the Obama administration
to handle the overflow of young people
illegally crossing the border on their
own now almost 10% of the children
living here have been separated from
their families homeland security
secretary Kirsten nielsen insists the
children at all facilities are well
cared for we operate according to some
of the highest standards in the country
we provide food medical education and
all needs as a child request there are
more than 100 shelters in 17 states
currently housing undocumented minors
who stay for an average of 57 days
according to a former agency employee
that number has gone up under President
Trump and with it the cost to taxpayers
we need to find solutions immigration
advocate Julio Calderon was once housed
in a shelter like homestead he says
facilities nationwide are feeling the
strain because of the over capacity now
it's not just at the border it's not
just an issue happening at the border it
has spread out the lawmakers were turned
away because of a government policy
request to visit must be made at least
two weeks in advanced but a former HHS
administrator told us that given the
current concerns about minors being
separated from parents requests from
lawmakers he believes can and should be
expedited Gail okay Adriana thank you